what's up man yeah um thank you I'm good
um I just wanted to ask like a sort of
um a fun question first for everyone as
well not just you guys so just sort of
who would you say out of the Bible sort
of like prophets and apostles or for
Muslims in the comment prophets and
sahabah are most reflective of your
character and your life and your story
like who would you guys say like because
I'm going to rewatch this and read the
comments I want everyone to sort of like
just give her something you know just
something like we could actually discuss
instead of go at each other sort of like
oh Christianity is this Islam's that you
something a bit nicer you what I
mean well I'll I'll I'll say this I
matter of fact I'll let the uh I'll let
the comment section say me yeah yeah
comment section what if if there's a
prophet or anybody in the Bible that
most that I most resemble who do you
guys think it is I I want to see what
the comment section says yeah yeah yeah
I wanted to just see what again so when
not because I'm gonna rewatch this you
know see what people say different sort
of like opinions you it's something
funny as well just for everyone to talk
something positive you know I mean
instead of oh snap I got a
Samuel
Solomon okay all
right yeah also thank you everyone for
yesterday sort of like comments that you
gave me both positive and negative like
honestly that both of the positive and
negative comments that you gave me
personally it's just making me stronger
so thank you all as well oh that's
awesome man that's awesome somebody
remind them of Aisha it's
crazy that's
wild someone said David someone said I
can't believe someone said Solomon man
you know Solomon he had uh yes some
trouble
[Laughter]
Man his I ain't got them problems man I
got Solomon's like man I I got read a
lot of books spent some time with some
honey bunnies I I planted a garden my
man had too much time with this
bro hey man so yeah so back to the topic
now about the New Testament yeah um one
thing I'm like sort of struggling to
understand is do you know like the sort
of uh I think it's Matthew Chapter 5
yeah chapter 5
17 57 um where it's talking about the
laws in the Old Testament that's sort of
going to be continued or
fulfilled what does that actually mean
in terms of law laws for
Christians what does what does it say
that in the passage that that's going to
be are you a
Muslim oh yeah so I'm Muslim but you
know it's I'm in the middle kind of okay
yeah okay yeah so this passage doesn't
doesn't really say what you're saying
all all he's claiming about is the idea
that he's not going to come and destroy
it and that the Torah is in existence
but a lot of people and people who don't
know the Hebrew Bible they would they
think that the the Torah or the law is
something that's static the law wasn't
static not even in the beginning when it
was given right and we have laws before
Moses goes to Mount Si and then we have
the laws that were given changing before
they even make it into the promised land
right so just you know so the law is not
static the law is something that's
Dynamic and adapts to a current
situation and condition and even in
Isaiah it talks about the coastlands
waiting for the Torah of the Messiah and
the New Testament tells us we're under
the law the namas christas the Torah tat
Masia the law of the Messiah right so
we're really under the law of the
Messiah which incorporates his View and
vision of the whole of the Bible right
because you can bring a Rabin Jew up and
he'd say he'd say I follow the Torah I
follow the Torah right and I'm like well
do you keep the laws of menstrual
impurity well no because those don't
apply to me do you do you follow the law
of the temple no there's no Temple do
you follow the laws of of oh so you're
saying that the LA has to apply to a
condition a time period That's relevant
for the law right so same thing when we
have when we go to Jeremiah 31 okay 31
look what he says let's uh let's go to
it real quick I think it's important if
you could pop that screen up real quick
Avery gotta a quick question as well um
yeah you know about this commentary that
you use um radar is that something I can
access or is it something that you've
made yourself or oh this this is
accordance module I told accordance they
need to stop playing in sponsor me
because I keep bigging them up on every
single
video I said they gotta come through and
give me a package or something you know
what I mean um but this is ACC
coordinance you can get all the modules
on here and they're available and you
can buy them in parts so the um program
is called the coordinat they have logos
logo seems a little bit better for most
people so all right we'll check this out
all right so this is Jeremiah 31 this is
basically the new C which we're in but
but he he doesn't just say a New
Covenant is coming he qualifies what
that New Covenant is and how it's
different he said days are coming when I
will make a New Covenant is Brites with
the house of Israel and the house of
Judah where where are the Gentiles well
the Gentiles joined the house of Israel
and the house of Judah they join God's
people right um but this part's really
important it's not like the Covenant
which I made with their fathers in the
day I took them by the hand to bring
them out of the land of Egypt why
because they broke my Covenant although
I was a husband to the Lord but this is
the Covenant which I will make I'll put
my law my Torah within them in their
hearts I'll be their God and they shall
be my people so the idea is that the New
Covenant has within itself a new Torah
not a Torah that eradicates what came
before but builds upon it refines it and
clarifies it and even the rabbis teach
that when the Messiah comes he's going
to bring us a new Torah with new
Commandments and he's going to CL
clarify for us everything they came
before and everything else we got wrong
so the rabbers are building upon this so
when Jesus talks about the he didn't
come to destroy it no he didn't come to
destroy what was before but he builds
upon it he clarifies it refines us and
gives us the true meaning like one
example that's really important you know
under the old Covenant you were able to
um divorce right and you were able to
have multiple wives Jesus clarifies
these things and says divorce is only
for what sexual immorality and then he
goes to say that it should only be one
man and one woman you shouldn't be
having multiple wives okay so he brings
the inner um the inner beauty of The
Commandments and even elevates the
Commandments the Torah tells us don't
commit adultery Jesus says don't even
look at a woman with lust because then
you've committed adultery in Your Heart
Right the Torah tells us don't un alive
don't kill Jesus says don't even hate a
person in many ways the Messiah is even
stricter than Moses and in other places
more lenient because he's given us the
true meaning of the Torah that was given
and it's his Torah that we so would you
say like pragmatis do you know what
pragmatism is in terms of break it down
what you mean what you mean by
pragmatism yeah so um what how I'm
trying to talk about pragmatism um is
sort of
gradual um like you said buildings upon
um law that we have um based off of like
understanding and sort of um
of the time as well so that's pragmatism
in terms of like political structures
yeah not necessarily religious what I'm
trying to say is through Christianity
does that idea sort of live or um
because for example in Sharia law it's a
totalitarian state where you essentially
don't have free speech right
so what I'm trying to say is oh God like
yeah so would you say the Christian
political structure is pragmatic or
not I think so a lot of people think
that oh you know you're in the New
Covenant now you're in something that's
new right and you're in something that's
uh you know different from what God gave
Moses I would say that what God gave
Moses is the thing that's new and then
when we're in the New Covenant we go
back to the original intent which
predated the the Torah that was given to
Moses on Mount sa and I'll prove it to
you from the Torah Exodus 25 gives these
stipulations for the Tabernacle where
the altars are going to be given its
association with the priesthood right
but look at Exodus 25:40 God says see
that you make them what the implements
and everything for the Tabernacle after
the pattern for them which was shown you
on the mountain so this is saying that
God showed Moses a Tabernacle in heaven
and that the one that Moses makes is a
copy
right right okay so so the one that's in
heaven is the real Tabernacle the one in
Earth is in the copy right so if there's
a Tabernacle in heaven what does that
mean so if the Tabernacle on Earth has a
priesthood then the Tabernacle in heaven
has a what a priesthood a priesthood
right so it's not that the priesthood of
melchisedec the priesthood of the
Messiah is the new one the priesthood
that the Messiah has is the original one
oh the one that Moses serves as a copy
and
Shadow okay okay so the Messiah in many
ways takes us back to the original
intent of God in our relationship to him
through a Heavenly priesthood so what
why why didn't like Moses what why did
why didn't we why didn't the Old
Testament originally start with the
original why did it have the original
then Moses's version and then Jesus
coming back to go to the original well I
think we have this idea right so people
see here you know Romans 10:4 says that
the Messiah is the end of the law right
this is the Greek word Telos this
doesn't just mean end though this means
goal I think it's much better to read
this as the Messiah is the goal of the
law for righteousness to everyone who
believes so the law on Earth the Torah
on Earth is meant to be a school Master
to bring us to the Messiah so we can
know the right way to live right it
shows our inadequacy before him and our
need for AED
redemer okay so would you say um because
I'm I'm actually really interested in
law and politics and as just like a side
subject right would you say like
Christianity does have a political
structure well I I don't think so
remember Israel is a monarchy basically
a monarchial system right ancient Israel
with God as king and I would ask you
like I've asked before on the stream
when did God ever ask for Israel to have
a
king
see God never asked Israel for a king
God should have always been the king
Israel asked for a king right but under
the New Covenant the body of Messiah is
not a political system there is no like
Christian Nation or Christian
nationalism like that the body of
Messiah encompasses local communities
spread throughout the world that make
that one group that is his body right a
across whatever it doesn't matter
cultural boundaries political
affiliations I mean there's some
politics we should have if we're
Believers but doesn't really matter what
you write on your voter's registration
card or what nation You Belong to You
belong to God's family the body of
Messiah the bride of Christ right so
that's that's what it is exactly and God
yeah God obviously has like his laws of
obviously what it means to be a believer
right yeah well I think yeah so go ahead
I don't want to cut you off because when
I have this discussion I've brought it
up multiple times where um as far as I
was concerned Christian doesn't actually
have like a a political
structure
um it can influence politics and it has
obviously what it believes to be right
and wrong that's not a political
structure whereas so when I when I was
debating Sharia law yesterday um like in
the debate I was talking about
um they brought this up the fact that
Christians obviously they got their law
from the the Torah um all this stuff
will be carried on so even their strict
law would be carried on so thank you for
clearing that up is basically saying I
didn't know that Jesus goes back to the
original um Heavenly Tabernacle Heavenly
tabernac that um was up there so yeah
that actually clears up quite a lot
thank you yeah and so I think I think a
lot of times we want to go back to a lot
of people want to go I want to go to the
church of Paul right and then people say
you know I want to go to the synagogue
of Moses right I want to be how it was
in Mount Si but the expectation for God
and and in cre was that he would have a
human family to Fellowship love with
have relationship with right and be able
to have this um engagement with his
creation that could be enjoyable but sin
gets in the way think about the Garden
of Eden gets in the way in the Garden of
Eden though there was a potential for
sin the only way to deal with the
potential for sin in humanity is the
path that we went on with the Redeemer
Messiah that there will be a time and
place where the redeemed of God would be
without sin and will be with him forever
freely choosing him with love that is
free love that's not forced because forc
love is not love this will be our
reality where sin is not a potential
Islam does not present this no other
religious system presents this because
sin is never dealt with in any other
system except for the biblical
worldview okay wait wait can you
elaborate what you mean on that last
Point as an ISL because Islam doesn't
have the the notion of the atonement
being fully paid by the Divine Son of
God right okay so if any other so the
the Tanakh the Hebrew Bible way before
Muhammad was a thought expresses the
idea that the blood of bulls and goats
are inadequate for the sins of humanity
why because you me we're made in the
image of God we reflect his nature his
being his at reflect we're not the same
but we're like him and we have this
sense of value and because we have this
awareness of God the book of Psalm says
that the heaven declares the glory of
God because we have this awareness of
God we have a responsibility to reflect
him rightly Romans 1:18 talks about this
right that people suppress the knowledge
of God we owe God our Allegiance and
obedience and right living because we
have an awareness of him being made in
His image that's why when we sin it is
an egregious crime against the Lord and
when your kitty cat sins because it
overeats you know it it's not sinning
right because your your cat doesn't have
an awareness of God
so because we have an awareness of God
when we sin it is an egregious crime
against the creator of the universe this
is why the Bloods and bulls and goats
cannot atone for you and I because of
blood because the blood bulls and goats
and animals don't have the awareness of
God so their innocence can't cover over
our
iniquity therefore we need a human being
to die for us okay here's the problem
though Adam every human has sinned and
fallen short of the glory of God
therefore we need God to take on flesh
born of of a virgin without a without a
sinful nature to die for you and I with
the authority to lay his life down and
pick it up from the other side of the
grave and being able to send the Holy
Spirit to enable people to walk in
Holiness and righteousness no other
system in the world Islam traditional
rinic Judaism or anywhere else solves
the problem of the debt that man owes to
a holy God okay okay so my next question
is um hold on pause there pause there
pause there sorry hold that thought if
you can if you don't forget it write it
down um but there was somebody talking
in the in the chat um radar he says that
you know anybody that challenges us we
we kick them so um I want to bring you
up sad are you
ready do you want me to mute sad yeah
yeah you yeah you could stay though you
don't have to leave or anything